this video is brought to you by expressvpn
and Shopify people more on them after the
reaction what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today so I am going to
do a first time watching for a movie that I am
very much looking forward to I've heard a lot
of good things about and I am the one at the
channel who hasn't seen it so it's a solo one
today and that is for the movie The Impossible
I know it's about a tsunami I know it stars a
young Tom Holland I'm very much looking forward
to it but guys what do you think about about
this movie leave your thoughts in the comments
down below did it affect you I hear this is a
strong film whatever that means powerful dramatic
moving tell me what you think about it what's an
impossible thing you've had to overcome that's
a more YouTuber question anyway guys listen go
ahead leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated be sure to subscribe
click that notification Bell to get notified
when we get a reaction up on this channel that
Peaks our interest because we got a lot in the
can that we have already shot also big thank
you to prepper for helping us head it down
these highlights lastly massive thank you to
all who have joined us at our patreon becoming
super sexy rejects over there you can catch the
full length ratch and watch along where you
snc up with your own copy of the impossible
also John and I cover several shows exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs included thank
you again to all of join is one of the absolute
best ways to support the channel plus you get
some extra goodies on top of that all righty
guys let's see what this movie is all about I
was trying to think of like an impossible
possible thing whatever let's just watch
it the deadliest tsunami on
record in the Southeast coast of
Asia admittedly selfishly not as familiar with the
story damn that is
unnerving whoa is a plane we were hearing
that's a really fascinating ating opening
capturing the like horror and Beauty Allin one
oh Naomi Watts is in this all I've ever heard
about is young Tom Holland and EV McGregor yes
did you set the alarm before we left yeah it
was the last thing I did what would the alarm
be I was the last one to leave and I'm sure I
didn't set it no darling I was the last one out
and I did you sure y you better go across that
aisle and berat her no no I was the last
one cuz I went back in I guess that means
we'll be coming home to a large bunch of hippies
sleeping in our bed just like your old College
days we're going to have a good day
everything's going to be great what
you doing it's time to sit down we're about
to land darling well talk to me which one's
Tom Holland just sit down and stop worrying
Place mad Lucas okay that's Tom all right
you know you could try being a bit nicer to
your brother he's just scared yes someone
else is new everything scar oh you're
going to wish you were nicer you little
[__] oh Christmas Eve this is a Christmas
movie perfect timing Greg you know exactly
what you're doing in the algorithm all resorts
are full but this area is really quiet grateful
families the Orchid Beach Resort is brand
new we just opened a week ago you love it
here everything's going to be great we made a
booking on the third floor the SE view room but
we feel you might play this better Smo is doing
an excellent job at getting you thrusted into
the Wonder and joy and then they're going to
flip it all upside down isn't it great dad can
we swim in there yeah we can go swimming yeah
it's going to be so much swimming you have no
idea all joking aside I can feel this is going
to be a really harrowing experience man 4 3 2
1 to this day I still don't know what that
is can you guys tell me in the comments I
suppose I could just Google it but it'
be more exciting if you told me in the
comments isn't going up it's going
a different way than all the other
it's going a different way than the others
kind of like what this family's going to do
I don't know who directed this but
I feel some certain Steven Spielberg
inspirational touches maybe a little
bit more edited than a Spielberg film
but there's certainly touches ear marks of him get
off it's
Christmas oh man it's going to be the
shittiest Christmas ever God damn man
a it's movies like this that really make
me wonder how they built the chemistry
oh my God young Spider-Man it's movies
like this that made me wonder how they
built the chemistry with actors like
how much improvising they had them do
together or what the rehearsal process
was like or what the director had them
do just to get to know each other as
the chemistry of the family feels very
authentic are they going to give any
backstory to how they're young boys able to do
backflips must be Jack man this movie thrives
on the atmosphere of the sound
design you can just hear that
fan just close your eyes and think of
something nice that's that's going to
be a trick that really comes in handy you're
hopeless what I'm going to hide that thing and
forget where I push it I I was just checking
to see about the house would put a bit on in
Japan that phone is going to be very much
necessary at a situation that's upcoming
they can't fire you that would be too expensive
don't worry well I do worry because we can't
afford to lose this job can we especially
with what's coming up now or maybe it's
going to feel frivolous in the end maybe it's
time oh you want to go home it's not the West
idea is it they're a Spanish family they're
like Spanish like like a West as a Spanish
right oh [__] again the way they just
know how to like the sound design is so
specific and there's some amazing framing here
oh like all chills everywhere nipple chills
included oh my God oh my
God wa that looks
real
oh my
god oh that's so horrifying this family survive
that that is so
unnerving
Jesus
Christ oh how horrible oh man it is so
tragic that this [__] like this really
happens oh what he damn that looks shockingly
real
holy oh God you go after
your kid in a situation like
that oh no ooh this move is
really already getting to
oh it's just a hard hard
experience oh this is so kinetic I want to go gra
my oh [__]
yo I don't know how they made
this movie for damn this look
real God damn
it now the additor on this is
superb that's a miracle this Ser
oh my God you got to be kidding
me oh
oh so
shr a poor
kid no did did that is that what
happened Holy balls yo this is such I I'm already
like I want to like pause the move
and be like what happened in real
life
I'm here damn
it here that this is tragic
man
careful don't move o boy I didn't I
think this would be so suspect that
to be a little emotional oh you
just feel like how harsh in that
desperation for a family to survive
it's just these two right now I'm
scared I'm scared
to ah this some great for boing string
music
who who made this movie this is this done
so well already I don't know why my mind
was like is this a lowbudget film I don't know
anything about like the behind the scenes at
all oh oh my God holy crap whoa is this an R-rated
movie you come oh she is like oh
no it's okay I can't see you like this okay sorry
is just I can't see you like this oh wow how do
you survive with an open wound like that do
this oh so like the infection that would take
place whoa oh that tree there the
big one do you think we can climb
it oh God I can't believe
that damn you a real badass
mom I feel so naive for not realizing at
all what I was walking into it's just like
a straight up survival horror drama did
you hear that b there's nothing we can do
we have to to get to safety we have to help
that boy mom if another wave Catches Us down
here we will die uh yeah that is conflicting
mom look at you we need help you cannot risk
it damn young Tom Holland you a good little
kid actor man what if that boy was Simon or
Thomas you'd want someone to help them wouldn't
you Simon and Thomas are dead whoa hey little
Lucas even if it's the last thing we do even
if it's the last thing we do act of Love look
there m i see wow the sets they built for
this I'm like in an admiration of the The
Duality of wow this all really happened
to look how they put this together for a
movie what's your name I'm
like waiting for some terrible
injury Tree of Life to just go from this like
luxurious Escape getaway to feeling the most
Primal hey got your drink somewhere the
hotel manager is keeping track of you kid
guys this movies mom coming down just give me
a sec I can do it Mom I'm coming down I can
do it Lucas just try to keep it together
keep your composure together for your son
huh oh God damn it oh you could really feel it
it's like my my whole like leg is just tingling
jeez
God that Andrew Gordon must be
influencing me because when he
was pushing him up I did have that
flash in my head of like Get Up
Spiderman God even like a little knee
scrape seems so much worse than usual
this is one of those movies that
if you told me the what the actors
were injured on set or whatever
got scrapes I completely believe
it a little Daniel
look at that you know you did the right thing
you did the right thing Mom
look look they're coming for
us man this movie win an Oscar for
sound design cuz you can feel every
little tiny thing like that sound
right now just scraping up against
I don't like it I'm sorry to get a headache
oh [__] really starting to get a headache
from just watching this I don't even never even
been remotely close to a situation like these
people oh hell yeah where you
go villagers thank you so much
she is excellent at showing the uh the pain and
exhaustion these are really good
people was Daniel Daniel Daniel yeah
where is Daniel yeah what happened to
Danel
passing the Wailing of all these
suffering victims Man Too Much
Too Much wow that took me a second to
register what was on the back of that
truck so Lucas is the main character
of this story thought it might just be
a small supporting role for
some reason so cold in here
cold oh we need to get her some medicine
badly I need some antibiotics look in the
cup I can't read the labels they're all in
tight there's got to be some English look oh
look at the S side I I'm at a point where
I would just take anything oh please see
that boy I'm always got in the world did you
understand a are you okay that my husband two
children this poor child and Mom all the
countless other people really a miracle
they're alive what color is it my leg is
it still red yeah it's still red it's good
as long as it doesn't turn black well hell yeah
hell yeah the red legs need to eat on eat it so
bossy what's your name my name's
Maria and this is my son Lucas how
much loss has this woman experienced give us some
Tangerine be careful whoa turn your head to the
side please we'll choke if you don't please oh God
okay okay the hell's happening what the hell's
happening mom momy you all right what are you
doing oh my
goodness what the is happening I don't know
Anatomy science trauma [__] enough to know
what's happening what is going on here what
are they both going through right now after
you guys comment and tell me what's happening
with those lamps that people do in movies you
tell me what's going on here I don't know what's
happening man you got to go and do something
go and help people you're good at it what you
want me to do something anything there's just
something about doing good things in a time where
it seems really hard too it really gets to me man
B [__] from Sweden Sweden Morton
Joseph I'll try and help you are
you are you Joseph benom or Morton
benom Morton benr excuse me excuse
me uhhuh I'm looking for my My Son Your Son
uh Peter Berry two first AES Anie Mar Brown
sure what's your name again Anna Marie the
brown anyone wow he's just getting a whole
list is so
touching he hasn't even able to cross off
one name she get a clipboard [__] benom
no way oh my God I know your dad Papa you yeah
your papa he's here I'll bring him here okay
yes bring him you have to stay here because
it's a very long way and you have to rest
okay holy [__] man this is
something else man it is so so
touching b like just fighting that
hope where are you no these
people
more Spiderman than Spiderman this
is like something you do with the
Spider-Man game I I really am going
to be soet she's like dead or moved or
something she was moved wasn't
she oh [__] she's not dead
though right where's my mom no no what are you
doing yo little take it easy boy no my
mom was and she took a file you have
to come with me I will help you give some
answers too I really hope she ain't dead
goes without saying pretty obvious statement
to make right now I really hope she's not
dead this movie decides to go it's
got this incredible ability to go
like handheld and then to do go handheld and
do slow moving shots that get just force
it it staps your brain to focus with the
film it's going to be okay man
you're going to make it through
worst I just can't wrap my head
around being in a situation like
this I can't do it like ah this
trailer dropped I got to get back
home oh wait a minute is this is even
McGregor these are bigger legs is is
this him or is it somebody else oh my god
daddy lives Lucas honestly he looks great
compared to everyone else we've seen Lucas
Mar that frame rate shutters speed shift if
he's only shouting for them he might have the
other two boys right or he only cares about
Lucas Mo everyone here this
point I'd be trying to get a
refund oh my God you got to be kidding me hey
man you all right just until I here a minute
you're sending trucks to drive us all up to the
mountains can you tell them I'm back yes dad dad
a whole load of helicopters just flew by why don't
you come down here a minute Thomas man these are
good parents I still haven't found them did you
see a lot of dead people that's a question can
we leave yet I need need to do me a favor Thomas
I've heard that everyone's going to the mountains
you see to our shelter where it's really safe
damn his eye is jacked up I did not even notice
but I can't go with you I I have to keep looking
for them you see you have to look after some I've
never looked after someone before when I came
up that was all on my own that was the scariest
part and then I saw the two of you clinging to
the tree and I I didn't feel so scared anymore
because I knew I wasn't on my own you see what if
Mommy and Lucas are on their own right now imagine
how scared they'll be you have to look after
Simon and I'm going to keep looking for them
yep I wonder what they change structurally
compared to the true story and the uh narrative
is smart you know like oh you know if if
Maria was just fine we be here going all
right they just got to reunite but we don't
know what happened to Maria she alive could
I use your phone will be really quick our
battery's almost dead we need the phone
wow fascinating this is when you get that take
care of your own kind of survival Instinct see
you in the morning okay you're not coming
I'm not coming we might know Thomas I'll
take care of you all right and stay with
this group wow you got to leave your two
little boys behind with a bunch of strangers
it's such a desolate situation will you look
out for my boys for me please come with
us I know it's useless don't say that
wow this side of town sucks I love you
I'll be with you tomorrow promise I love
you I would have loved it if you
McGregor got unnecessarily jacked for the
role oh she going to walk Barefoot through
this this hey man you okay get in the car
we'll drive you somewhere safer physical turmoil
acting in this is so good it is such good acting
heart-wrenching pain my little girl Gina she's
just too the noise woke me up and saw the sea
coming in land it took me 5 Seconds to reach the
stairs but the water was already there on the bed
I found a note from my wife saying that they
were at the beach a yeah my whole family were
around the swimming pool when the water hit
I found my middle son first Thomas and then
I found my little one Simon sent them to the
mountains so that I could keep looking for my
wife and my eldest son damn that is hard have
you called home yet I can't find a phone I'm
saving my battery just in case my family calls
I'll be very quick I promise a little hope in
his eyes of all I got a phone Ryan yes hry thank
God did you hear from anyone yet no you're the
first to call is everybody all right M came and
swept everyone away and I found I found Thomas
and have to go lots of people need to
use his phone okay call it I don't know
what's at always was situation like this
truly is like but this feels surreal to
me I promise you I I won't stop looking
until I find him okay I don't know what
I'm going to do cuz it's night time now
but I I'll look in all the hospitals and
I I will find them I promise you that I'll
call you when I do my nose can I go with
you just hanging on to that hope hanging
on to someone else's hope there's lot of
love in this movie dark as it is like
looking at stars don't you I can find
most of constellations some of those stars have
been burnt out for a long long time how can you
tell which ones are dead and which ones are
not no you can't it's impossible there's the
title of the movie he's describing what's
happening in the movie even these random
actors who show up provide so much depth you
feel like full-fledged character your name is
Lucas Bennett is that right and your mother's
name is Maria Bennett is that correct huh
we'd like you to look at these things please
and see if you recognize any of them that is
a loaded question is that you promised me you
weren't going anywhere I thought you were dead
Mom how is she she's had
surgery on her chest okay the
sheers this is such a daunting overwhelming
experience
I appreciate the attention detail
too even in these montages this
the chaos and the Clutter of all the
extras very well just orchestrated
film wasn't she on the truck where
are my kids they're taking in my
way they wouldn't let me go with him I'm
sorry where I don't know oh my God what
now it just doesn't end they really
sell you on the the title here the
Daniel little angel
boy and if you didn't choose to save that
little boy he wouldn't be with his dad right
now if I was little Tom holl L Lucas here I
want I want the credit I would have gone right
up to the dad like you don't know what I did
for your kid color is my leg please don't be
black it's black isn't it still R is he
lying he dropped that sheet pretty fast
this movie just has his hope never mind her
wound's looking really bad we are doing the
best we can we are taking your mom to surgery
right away why does this woman play it am I
am I just misreading it I I feel like there's
a something kind of antagonistic about her or
something I feel like she should be kind of
comforting we have checked all hospitals but
this one 5 minutes please just only 5 minutes 5
minutes how could you check this Hospital in 5
minutes anything left in the C the can don't worry
I'll get you something guys my head is pounding
some has just this incredible ability to thrush
you to the mood girl this bikini just walking
around all C you got to be kidding me you got
to be kidding me movie this is some movie [__]
right here this not what how it's not how it went
down in real life this is some frustrating movie
[__] these sideways tracking
CHS these Paul Thomas Anderson
shots you got to be fre stuff like
this frustrates me so much no way
did he find her please she's turning
into a zombie right now please find
her better not be the movie just messing with
me I'm going to stab someone this
is so frustrating and like right
there oh [__] oh you would know you're
that feels so real you you would you
could know you could identify your dad
from [__] like that you know someone
that well you can recognize their lower
half unless there's some other detail I'm
missing I just if there is let me know
to me I'm like yeah feel like you just
tell
shout his actual name I would just shout dad a
lot of people probably shout
dad need a pink can you hold
it Simon what are you doing Simon says I need to
pee it's the most miserable part of the
movie
sign pay attention to the
signs the tug and pull this movie
does there
new this movie is something I got to
look up what happened to this this family
agressively shouting his St at
him this is is really really
moving I just find the dad would
you Lucas you are the C Beast to all
this
luas Dad Lucas
did it we did it it did the we did The
Impossible look who's
here oh my God she's a
completely different color my
oh man I I I don't know if I can take it
if she dies I don't know if I can take
it we're all
okay this my mind even going
there is like man am I that no no
you back yes I was so not prepared for this
fil God I can rest now I don't know what that
means what does that mean oh no no
no don't do it you're going to be
fine that's not why I came here for you're going
to be fine they're going to take good care of you
okay promise you we're going to be fine I promise
you you're going to be okay we're taking her to
surgery she better live alls oh boy I love
you you going to be okay wow this is really
something I I got like pic just traveled
from like here to the back of my right
eye there's this BL little girl that hutter
hutter whose nose is always clogged and now
I know what it feels like to be her what
you just can't blow your nose Lucas thanks
for taking care of Mom we took care of
each other oh boy yeah he did there's
something I didn't tell I really need her
to know or love her I don't know what was
it hey I have a family too she speaks I
been safe in my strength because I want
to see that uhuh one more time totally
I get it kind of I I mean I don't know
really but you're in good hands close
your eyes and think of something nice
that is like the nerd reoccurring nurturing
element that line please for the love of God
live that is not something nice to think
about
wow
is a God damn nightmare
whoa holy [__] Ser like oh
God God God God God God God
God wow
wow it feels like true nightmare
true nightmare right now come
on metaphorical [__] rise above
the water for the love of goddess
and wow gorgeous it's like choosing
to have lived in spite of it all
rebirth Mom's okay
Lookers we're going home that was kind of a
way to approach it you do exactly the entire
time he's walking over you're doing a walk of
I got bad news for you son I'm all T hole from
zerich insurance that sent me to take care
of your family in a few hours you'll be at
Singapore General Hospital wow how are you
here with you guess what I saw Daniel again
yeah that's right she didn't going to hear that
you're so happy save that boy he in somebody's
arms I bet it was his dad I certainly
hope so my God can you imagine some other
guy I love you so much guys I
I am drained what a beautiful
story about like just the Stars story about the
stars that was part me kill her
off wow what a shot to addon is final shot of the
movie that's a
miracle that you can survive
that could barely handle bump on my head on like a
wall God damn right wow
what a film what a powerful
film oh my God it's the real
family those are real names too oh I want
more whoa that's is my favorite
Tom Holland performance man I
got a blow my nose I got such a
headache I got such a bad headache
but you know what it doesn't give me a headache
these guys thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use for our merch store and is
our gamechanging partner in eCommerce so whether
you're launching a passion project or scaling to
new heights Shopify is the e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating your first
online store to opening physical locations Shopify
makes it seemless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique Collectibles
thanks to their all-encompassing platform for
both online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective at
converting visitors into buyers than other
platforms and let's not forget Shopify magic the
AI tool that elevates your business with minimal
effort but seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www.re nation shop.com it's
been transformative the transition smooth growth
exponential thank you again reject Nation from
simplifying sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success and Shopify
isn't just for us it Powers 10% % of us e-commerce
backing businesses big and small in over 175
countries there are war-winning support always
there to guide you so ready to join the revolution
sign up for Shopify at only a dollar a month at
shopify.com rejects all overc case shopify.com
reject start your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's right
years so whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about Express
PM for online privacy and security but there's
more to it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum Shing on my
internet and contacting me due to a suspecting
hacking attempt and funny enough I realized I
hadn't actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced a serious
hacking issue on YouTube a couple years ago that
made expressvpn my go-to for both security and
freedom I mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you can use
expressvpn to watch movies and shows on Netflix
that are not available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your fingertips
it's super easy open expressvpn switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC I
player YouTube or more expressvpn has you covered
and it's incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's versatile too
working on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere any screen
protect and elevate your internet experience so
if you want to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you can get
an extra 3 months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to expressvpn.com
reex to learn more thank you again all right
guys I just blew my nose I've pulled up IMDb
and all I have learned in this time is that
ja bota directed this movie I did not catch
that at all in the credits that's not surprising
what I wanted it there it is Jesus Christ been
looking all over for it I was trying to find the
trivia I wanted to read the trivia and then I'll
talk about this movie if you guys are listening to
this on Apple and Spotify please rate this video
just watch The Impossible uh the 2012 movie I
heard that oh was about the tsunami and I was
like can't I imagine there probably going to be
a few emotional moments in here but I I was not
expecting to be as enveloped in the experience I
didn't really know what part of me was actually
wondering if it was just going to be a bit of
a Ted if I'm being totally honest I was kind of
wondering if it would be a bit of a tedious drama
of okay maybe there's tsunami attack and then it
gets a little dull afterwards but that film that
had me engaged for many a reason uh that I will
go into but I wanted to look at the trivia really
quick here all right here we go haven't read any
of this yet the scene where the tsunami hits the
resort can only be filmed once it would have cost
too much money to rebuild the set what what does
that mean how do they film it then how do I don't
understand many of the extr were actual survivors
of the tsunami that's really cool I mean not cool
that they're survivors of the tsunami but the
fact that they actually use real survivors of
just again I did not under I don't know what it's
like to be in a situation like this but a register
to me is feeling authentic um according to Naomi
Watts the producers of the film heard an interview
on Spanish radio where the family told their s
their story of surviving the tsunami and decided
to make a film Bas on it that's really that's
really neat they were Spanish right that's bit
I don't know I don't really I guess they could
be well one thing I liked about it too that
I thought was really cool because I could see
this being one of those movies that is accused
of whitewashing um is that it's not one of the
trivia facts here maybe it's here somewhere but
I haven't got there yet uh but one of the things
that I thought was kind of neat about it is that
uh they they put a a good amount of emphasis too
on the it was the the actual people who Liv there
who immediately went to go help the tourists you
know this like a lot of people died and we didn't
really focus on the people who lived there and so
much of their homes and many of those lives were
probably taken as well well and they put so much
Focus here on they went to go help the tourists
the people visiting I think that was something
kind of beautiful actually man the performances
are so good I don't know what that has to do
with the whitewashing but it it I don't know I
didn't really think about the that there might
be a whitewashing thing thrown out here I bet
there was though unless Naomi watchs Spanish and
I don't know that it took a year to put together
the 10-minute sequence a recreation of the moment
the wave Came Crashing Down the luxury hotel what
who whoa so they really did that [__] did
they really that's [__] wild the crew film
partially on location at the actual Resort since
rebuilt where the bone family was holiday when
the tsunami hit for the tsunami destruction scenes
a scale model of the resort was used they really
wanted to capture they wanted to be true to this
this the filmmakers had a sense of Integrity here
the real family of the main characters are based
on are fact Spanish but live in Japan at the time
of the tsunami ah makes a lot of sense for the
underwater scenes Naomi Watts was strapped in a
rotating chair while filming Watts couldn't hold
her breath any longer and she gave the stop sign
instead of stopping the chair started spinning
the other way around whoa later revealed that
it was a technical error and Watts stated that
she felt very scared and hated the chair for
that reason why wouldn't you wow that's Saturday
top all it's feature film debut that's impressive
the real color of the kids ball was yellow not
red this film's a liar Maria Bel said it was the
biggest lie in the film yeah if that's the biggest
lie in the film I can imagine that a lot of this
was probably surprisingly true Naomi Watts was
nominated uh as rightfully so man was she great
wait Best Actress Oscar n performance was the
only one in the category not in the best pitcher
nominee the year oh this film was not nominated
for best if it did not get on in for sounded on
I'd be shocked the opening scene is a point of
view uh well we'll look at that later uh I'm just
trying to see like the shorter ones this is one
of The Blacklist 2010 Blacklist a list of the most
UN most liked unmade scripts of the year I always
love hearing a story like that when a script is uh
like the is great but it's never going to get made
and then it eventually gets made oh that's really
great okay all right this movies PG-13 I really
thought it was radar I guess it's the handling
of the nudity and the violence that hopes with
it all uh yeah all right let's talk about the
actual movie I'm semi like multitasking at the
same time right now cuz my mind is just fixated
on [__] uh I was obviously very moved by it I
one thing that I thought was really I frame one
thing that I thought was really one thing that
I thought was really interesting about the the
script the first thing about the the scripting
of it all was the the dialogue choices uh were
I felt like this is how how would I put it how
would I put it um there's like a the movie has
so much emotional impact and just the right
amount of sentimentality And yet when they
had these dialogue scenes I would I would feel
like these this is still like what they would
talk about in the moment you know they wouldn't
do a bunch of this backstory stuff it it was one
of those films where it was so focused on the
immediacy of the situation and you're kind of
being plucked into the lives of what these
characters are experiencing Ing and what I
I loved all that that whole speech about the like
the the stars and that they're dead but you could
find a bright light it's like and talking about
the things that are impossible and you know I I
love me a good Bleak dark hering movie and and
this is that but it's also really contrasted
with this family's resilience to keep enduring
and not lose hope in the face of hopelessness
on on the Name of Love and and it was that kind
of [__] that just kept breaking me for from
beginning to end because this is such a heroic
Tale But it's about these just regular people
it's a it's it's an extraordinary story about
Ordinary People ordinary extraordinary people are
ordinary people who do things extraordinarily well
is that the quote I don't even know that applies
to the situation right now uh but but that's
what was great is it's fun it's fun I made it
like a little crack about this is more Spider-Man
than Spider-Man because to me this is capturing
more of why we really would love a Peter Parker
because they're doing all the literally the things
that most people would probably not want to do and
making these choices like saving the little Daniel
boy uh in the face of times where you were a lot
of times in these survival stories at least the
fictional I was ones you're kind of just looking
out for yourself but this is about aiding each
other and not losing faith and and and again the
the the word of endurance is the thing that just
keeps standing in mind and and I love how there
there was such a there there's a bit of that
Hollywood in the beginning you know like Hey we're
gonna have a great trip today you know we're ain't
nothing you guys say Walk Hard ain't nothing bad
G to happen today do we and just setting up the
fact that something terrible is going to happen
but you needed that you you needed that J the
position you you needed that Switcheroo to kind of
plop you into what it must have been like to be a
tourist vacationing at this wonderful Immaculate
Resort and then have one of the most devastating
things ever happened to you and because a lot of
people died in this event and then uh and if you
were lucky to survive it's like what injuries did
you sustain afterwards the trauma that you had to
endure I I so like as much as there's a bit of
like a hollywoodism in the way it was rid you
know I I still thought it was necessary to get
there and by the time you get to the tsunami and
but the acting was just so consistently great that
it was so believable from beginning to end and by
the time you get to the tsunami incident like even
the way that's captured in that perspective where
it just hits you suddenly it's not this big giant
buildup like a roll and emeric movie you're not
watching The Day After Tomorrow where it's like
thunder in the sky or whatever it's just a couple
of things with the blender and oh a couple little
noises and then hits you that must to put you into
the again it's I love a movie that focuses on POV
and the movie did such a great job on knowing how
to intercut between not intercut but cut around
depending and and gate with certain characters on
certain uh point of views for an extended period
of time like there was times I was going oh this
is Naomi Watts's movie oh this is Tom Holland's
movie oh this is Eva McGregor's movie you know
the way they would cut around to the characters
and let you stay in their perspective I thought uh
the direction of this combined of course with the
incredible acting man what would the homework like
that's the kind of questions I always try to find
more of the trivia on that's usually not IMDb like
I would love to know the trivia on that like Naomi
Watts did she sit down with the real Maria and how
many time how long she talk with her for how much
of the conversation she have to really get in her
mindset into hey let's talk about this moment and
what were you going through and how therapeutic
might have been for Maria to have been able to
talk through that with her was it therapeutic was
it difficult to um resurrect these conversations
and resurrect these memories and what it must
have been like for Maria to see that as me wats is
portraying it those kind of sequences you know um
those it got my mind pondering and but at the same
time you know this film has has such great visual
storytelling because you're relying so much on an
actor's performance and Body Language expression
it's not heavily ring there's it's not really
like Exposition heavy or they take the time to
reflect on a memory and just talk about the past
like there's something kind of inspiring to me I
could see two versions where some might not like
so much about the dialogue in certain key scenes
uh but to me I thought the dialogue was really apt
for this kind of for for what they want to portray
here you know they at the end of the day this is
about flopping the audience into the experience
of this real Stark uh impactful nature disaster
uh with emphasizing the emotional dramatic weight
throughout but everyone's so good in it my
mind's spinning my headache has not g away
at all if if you only have listen to this apple
spottify I felted a pretty big migraine and I'm
just trying to stay focused here uh the the the
I guess if I were to rank perform man this really
this is Tom Holland's debut role and and uh while
I do would ultimately go to me it's like a tossup
between Naomi Watts and Tom Holland is who's the
who's the lead in this movie like who do you guys
consider the lead in this film cuz I could see
it being Naomi Watts uh but in a lot of ways to
me it was Lucas Lucas to me felt like this the
central character and I and I thought that was
such an interesting narrative Choice some stuff
you could kind like at the stuff at the hospital
I wonder how real that was with oh my God they're
right there just look over your shoulder if you
just pay attention you could see them towards the
end but if [__] works on you when when it goes
down that path it works man you know you're just
getting frustrated and then you're aware it's a
movie but damn I'm just so caught in the moment
that I'm like I don't care some stuff you got
to you got to have some of that dramatic ump for
a situation that I'm sure was way more dramatic
in real life uh but I thought overall this movie
had very strong Direction uh it was engaging from
beginning to end uh the the ability to focus
on the human aspect instead of the disaster
actually helped Elevate the the everything about
the disaster wasn't about just going through like
the psychological experience I I thought the the
balance of it was was so Grand where you could the
after effects of the disaster are are the enemy
of the sto of the story and and it's like the like
the the antagonist of the story is like the it's
so interesting when you think about it because the
you know of course it's not one of those movies
where there's a clearcut antagonist you know or
you're dealing with there's another tsunami coming
and we got to we got to go after the antagonist
of the story is all the obstacles they got to
overcome and and also uh overcoming hopelessness
over and and enduring your faith against that like
that is those are the antagonist qualities you're
dealing with here and to me the disaster elements
that maybe perhaps make great trailer moments I I
think were sorry guys my head is so pounding uh
I think the disaster elements um just resonated
throughout and I never lost sight of the horror
of that because when you think about the disaster
elements of the spectacle of it the only way
that really stays effective is a you need your
investment in your characters and you you want
to see what what what this really does do as a
turmoil and the way they would still show once in
a while like oh they're traveling on the road and
you're seeing like these dead bodies uh or you're
seeing like people you know um in agony shouting
stuff out or the physical deterioration or the
symptoms like the prolonged effects I felt the
disaster elements were kind of non-stop or even
when you know uh Naomi wats in the Village People
are like dragging her after they rescued her and
you could just hear the scraping against her legs
like those the the spectacle of the disaster stuff
still permeated throughout the film I felt like it
was still very much alive because you can only do
the tsunami one time and the sequence of surviving
in the flood one time and I I thought that that
that spectacle that they probably pit you on still
was there in just different ways and and I found
that really impressive and it man it just plays on
your emotions because this movie there could be
like tragedy poring in and and this movie to me
was not that it it had it was a bit structurally
predictable at a certain point when you would go
from you know tragedy and hope but overall because
like a lot of times hopeful thing happened that
means in like I don't know 30 seconds we're going
to get something really tragic or something to
be really worried about you know so we kind of do
that like there's certain writing books I I think
Robert M I don't it doesn't exactly obey this
but there's like the I forget the name of that
Robert mck book is uh but you know some people
say that every scene if it starts off positive
has to end negative or every scene that start
negative has to positive you know some type of
simple way of understanding an arc of a scene so
you can kind of see some of that predictability
uh with within the structure of like when they
saw Daniel um at the hospital it's like he's
gonna go back something Terrible's goingon to be
with the mom or after he finds Swedish boy he's
going to go back there's going to be something
terrible because that's the tragedy hope tragedy
hope tragedy hope but overall um I wasn't always
hyper aware of it and even when I was it worked
that's the thing it's the emotion of like at the
end of the day no matter what logical you know
technical aspects even for a viewer like myself
that I can be aware of I would I I would still
just be so in the moment regardless that it was
the emotion that would be overtaking and to me
that is what Cinema is that that is what movies
are and and I I think this film just excelled
at that so much uh I thought it was beautiful I
thought it was it really it was a beautiful film
um and it brought me to tears nonstop and the uh
just the the focus on Humanity compassion in the
face of this disaster with not a real emphasis on
negative behaviors I'm so used to survival stories
and I mean normally survival stories can be often
apocalyptic and you're looking at like the worst
of the wor worst I mean we just saw the movie like
Leave the World Behind on Netflix which is a rely
like sci-fi kind of film and and um and that has
that quality of like look out for your own in the
face of the danger like the the worst of humanity
comes out and it's it's kind of refreshing to see
a a survival horror film that feels apocalyptic
and and it's about um human beings coming together
you know cuz uh I saw some I don't remember where
I heard this on uh I think it they were saying it
was Charles Darwin who who said it that the start
of humanity like what's what's allowed human means
to progress is I'm probably getting this wrong but
the way I have the way I have um internalized it
for all my life has been something I'm so focused
trying to get the quote wrong but here's how I
interpreted it or or here's how I remembered it at
least is is that is love and cooperation I believe
the the the the EMP just is want cooperation and I
I might have applied the word love underneath that
because I feel like every emotion comes down to
love or fear and this movie to me shines a light
on that the love and cooperation side in spite of
all this you know and I'm not someone who is often
I I feel like I'm so much in my own bubble a lot
of the time that I don't take enough time to like
learn about other things around the world enough I
try to I really do um it's often very very late at
night right before go to bed where I'm like you
know what I'm feeling inspired oh my God I'm in
a really dark place now because I've decided to
learn about some stuff and that I'm just on my
phone researching for like hours asking my wife
questions because she knows about all this stuff
and I don't um and yeah yeah yeah this is great
this is great and also like the emphasis on um
I don't know uh trauma and Recovery is is another
way to put it and um it just kind of reframes the
way you how would influence the severity of and
impact of natural disasters like tsunamis you know
it's something that out here you know I'll hear
about it's the way I hear about a lot of terrible
things that happen but after a while when you just
hear about it on the news it just becomes a thing
you hear about right something that you it becomes
information you become numb hearing about which is
terrible it's but it's the reality of of how a
lot of us ultimately respond and this brings you
to oh my God yeah it's such like this so terrible
so terrible and I'll be stressing out about how I
gota I can't get my upload up on YouTube you know
like oh my God I got to work on the edit for this
video I gotta get notes on this video I gotta get
the thumbnail right I gotta do all this like my
mind was thinking to myself like I have a headache
right now but man what was the headache like for
them I should just endure this headache as I was
watching this movie oh man uh yeah I thought this
was a great film and thank you guys for being with
me and being patient and and you know it's it's
interesting when you're filming one of these
and you're by yourself because it just feels
like you're I have such an I I I do have I was
diagnosed one of the benefits of doing reactions
that I think is like really awesome is it it's
it's allowed me to express everything that goes
on internally with me more than like what is my
wife I'm I'm pretty respectful when with other
people if if there's like not not doing this my
wife and I it's kind of like exactly when there's
a camera pointed at me the way we just talk about
things everything is just on our mind throughout
the whole time and and uh I was diagnosed uh way
back when ADHD PTSD and type two bipolar right
and it's some random thought that hit me is having
the ADHD mind has really been great for me to be
here because I have so many thoughts that go off
when I'm watching a movie and it just allows me
to express all that and I feel like in real this
is real life for me I I feel like a lot of the
time I I have to in I have to like hold back
because I know people are can be like shut up
Greg I'm trying to watch the movie and maybe some
people feel that already when watching one of our
videos but what I love about this experience is
I'm like oh now it's a perfect excuse to get all
these thoughts out while I'm watching something
for the first time it's a great time all righty
guys uh thank you so much again much love happy
holidays and uh man it's a Christmas movie who
would have thought all right John pick a name
oh Brian Perry Brian Perry you know what you're
getting for Christmas this year you are going to
get a book about the best positions in the bedroom
yeah for when you're you're by yourself yes the
karma the K selfa yeah and I'm telling you self en
enjoyment I don't know what words get us flagged
here self self fun of oh there's a there is a
technical term for this damn self the technical
term get flag look what position you put us in
yeah jeez it's not one of the positions you're
going to enjoy though you're going to have a
great oh yeah you're going to people are going to
be like why is Brian never showing up for work oh
dude he's why Brian not at Christmas dinner with
us hean never has to leave the house again open in
the present went to his bedroom and now it's 2025
someone did such a good job yeah that they don't
need to do anything for Brian ever again you're
going to master the art of self-love yeah with
this book that I have personally written and drawn
my myself yeah and checked it for you specifically
custom made for you Brian Perry handbound on the
finest paper on the finest artisanal craft paper
that we could find at oh yeah man insert sticky
joke ha hey anyway Brian much love to you Merry
Christmas hope you have a great New Year and uh
say hi to the mirror for me buddy yes see you soon